digamos que este triángulo que se
encuentra aquí es equilátero o lo que es
lo mismo que todos sus lados son iguales
y digamos que su longitud es s lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es encontrar
una forma para conocer el área de este
triángulo equilátero en función de ese y
para hacerlo lo primero que voy a hacer
es dividir este triángulo en dos
trazando esta altura desde el vértice
superior y que sea perpendicular a la
base y también visitará a este ángulo
que las medidas de estos ángulos serán
las mismas ya hemos mostrado las
propiedades de los triángulos 30 60 90
en un vídeo en un triángulo equilátero
regular los ángulos miden 60 grados esto
es este ángulo que se encuentra aquí es
de 60 grados
si este es de 60 grados lo mismo pasa
con este otro que también es de 60
grados y este de arriba también es de 60
grados pero lo dividimos en dos así que
este ángulo será de 30 grados este
también será de 30 grados y la otra cosa
que también sabemos es que esta altura
también be secta a este lado es decir
esta longitud es igual a esta longitud
todo esto lo vimos de una manera más
rigurosa en el vídeo de los triángulos
30 60 90 pero lo que esto nos está
indicando es que cada lado mide ese este
lado mide ese por lo que esta longitud
que se encuentra aquí medirá ese
dividido entre 2 y si esta longitud es
ese entre 2 podemos utilizar lo que
sabemos de los triángulos 30 60 90 para
saber las dimensiones de esta altura que
se encuentra aquí el motivo que más se
hace referencia a esta altura es que el
área de un triángulo es un medio de la
base por la altura y si el lado pequeño
es es entre 2 y que es el opuesto al
ángulo de 30 grados si el lado opuesto
al ángulo de 30 grados
la altura que es el lado opuesto al
ángulo de 60 grados será raíz de 3 veces
es decir raíz de 3 s dividido entre 2 y
sabemos esto porque las proporciones de
los lados de un triángulo 30 60 90 son
que el lado opuesto al ángulo de 30
grados es 1 el lado opuesto al ángulo de
60 grados es raíz de tres veces y el
lado opuesto al ángulo de 90 grados la
hipotenusa es el doble o sea 2 así que
este es el lado más corto que es el
opuesto al ángulo de 30 grados el lado
opuesto al ángulo de 60 grados será raíz
de tres veces el anterior o sea raíz de
tres s sobre dos y entonces sólo nos
faltaría determinar cuál es el área de
este triángulo utilizando que la área es
igual a un medio de la base por la
altura del triángulo y bien cuál es el
valor de la base en este en el triángulo
completo es ese entonces ponemos ese y
cuál es la altura del triángulo y eso ya
lo encontramos
a raíz de tres veces s sobre dos y
multiplicamos todo veamos que tenemos en
el numerador bueno pues tenemos uno por
ese a raíz de tres por s lo que es raíz
de tres s al cuadrado y en el
denominador tendremos dos veces dos o
sea cuatro por ejemplo si tenemos un
triángulo equilátero del lado uno su
área será raíz de tres sobre cuatro si
tenemos uno de lado dos será dos al
cuadrado que es cuatro que dividido
entre cuatro me queda uno y obtenemos
raíz de tres lo que hemos obtenido es
una generalización